Hello!
Here are some bad news.
It seems like chatbots are the reason why
the future chatbots will not get smarter but
rather dumber than the current ones.
Or at least, this is the worst-case scenario
this paper presents: if the future Internet
will be flooded by data generated by large
language models and the Internet will remain
the source of training data for future language
models, then these future models will degrade
a lot.
In this video, we will discuss what the problems
are with training models on data from other
models, how likely it is that the internet
of the future will contain almost only language
model generated data, which will help us to
assess if and how much this paper exaggerates
in its assumptions, which affects its conclusions.
Do you ever wonder how the chatbots of the
future can become better than the existing
ones?
By letting them ingest even more high-quality
data during training, or at least this seems
like the way to do it without any other innovation
besides the engineering tricks we are already
using.
And even with technical innovation, this is
machine learning after all, meaning that lots
of good training data is always a great idea.
But there is a limit to how much training
data we can get in the future.
Researchers extrapolated from past trends
how much unlabeled text and data
we can expect on the internet in the future
and conclude that high-quality text data will
be exhausted soon, likely before 2026 and
that low-quality text and image data will
be exhausted much later, between 2030 and
2050.
But machine learning researchers do not act
like they are much concerned with the worry
that our data production and storage rate
might not keep up with the appetite of large
models for data.
Who needs humans to produce data anyways,
because nowadays we can have generative AI
that can help with this!
Right?
Let’s see.
Researchers lately did not shy away from training
large language models on data synthesized
by other models.
The rationale of researchers at Stanford when
creating the Alpaca model was: We may not
have the data collection of OpenAI, but if
we finetune Meta AI’s LLaMA on data generated
by OpenAI’s text-davinci-003, then we can
make Alpaca mimic OpenAI’s model.
The Koala model from UC Berkeley was trained
on data from ShareGPT, which is a Chrome extension
where users can share their conversations
with ChatGPT.
Researchers have also used data generated
by models that were already trained with RLHF
to stand in for human demonstrations when
training other models with RLHF.
But this paper says that there is a danger
when recursively training models,
so it is a bad idea to train on data generated
by another model, which in turn was trained
on data from another model, and so on.
It sounds an alarm signal that recursively
training a model on a previous model’s outputs,
can lead to worse and worse models with every
training generation, and can lead to very
stark degradation of the last generation models.
At first, I thought the assumptions and experiment
settings of the paper are exaggerated and
we will discuss in the next part of the video
why they might be less exaggerated than I
initially thought.
But first, let’s see the three illustrative
experiments from the paper about model degradation
when trained recursively.
They are surprisingly simple, but bear with
them for a bit.
First, the authors work with a simple 2-dimensional
dataset consisting of 1000 points belonging
to two Gaussian distributions.
They fit a Gaussian Mixture Model onto the
data, which basically tries to find the parameters
of two Gaussians that best cluster the data.
From the fitted model, they sample 1000 points
and fit another Gaussian Mixture model on
this, and this goes on and on for 2000 generations.
And I know that 2000 generations seem a bit
over the top, but the point here is to see
the bigger picture of what small degradations
in each generation lead to: at each generation,
the shape of the original data is degraded
and already at generation 100 becomes unrecognizable.
At 2000 generations, they show that the estimation
of the distribution collapses into this tiny
region with very low spread.
Why like this and not differently?
Because the models of the first generations
train on data sampled from the early generation.
During sampling we see common events with
more probability and less common ones with
less probability, so because later models
see rarer events less, they more and more
forget these rare events of low probabilities.
The second reason is that later generations
of models entangle and remix different facts
that were previously learned well.
The reason for this is that models either
underfit the data and entangle different facts,
or overfit outside the sampled distribution
and invent new data points.
And this same message that we saw clearly
in the interpretable 2-dimensional space,
we see in the following more complicated experiments
as well.
The authors train a Variational Autoencoder
on the MNIST dataset for 20 generations, where
each generation trains just on data sampled
from the previous generation, so no real data
whatsoever.
We will discuss later whether this is exaggerated
or not.
The authors see that the Variational Autoencoder
at every generation degraded in its ability
to produce good looking digits and generation
20 produces all the same type of mixes of
digits.
So as previously, the models converge to just
one type of data with low variance and forget
the specificities that make up each individual
digit.
Then finally, language models.
Unfortunately, the authors do not pretrain
any language model, because they say it is
costly.
But arguably, they did not need to train GPT-3,
a small GPT-2 type model would have sufficed
to prove their point.
Instead, they finetuned a pretrained OPT language
model of 125 million parameters on wikitext2
in two settings: In the first setting, each
generation could not see any original data,
but just data from the previous generation.
In the second setting, finally they let the
model see some real data at each generation,
namely 10% real data and 90% data sampled
from the previous generation.
And as before, but now with language, the
9th generation models assigned high probability
to sequences that the original OPT model would
have never produced and started to talk gibberish,
which OPT would have never done.
The setting in which during training, each
model had access to 10% real data was generally
better than the setting without access to
real data.
But now, is this even realistic to conduct
experiments with just 10% real data??
First when reading the paper, Ms. Coffee Bean
thought that the paper bluntly exaggerates
their estimations because, come on!
They do their analyses and their experiments
based on the assumption that models only have
access to either no human produced data or
as little as 10%!
She thought this is a huge exaggeration and
I am just … confused why so much of the
Internet would be produced by AI -- in my
naivete: Only because we will use AI writing
assistants?
When writing, the interesting stuff is new
information, where language models can only
help a bit with the formulation, but not with
coming up with the new idea.
Yann LeCun was pointing out that the problem
with AI generated content is the dissemination,
not the writing.
The people using AI generated content would
have so much trouble finding people to read
the AI generated content, that they would
leave it be.
But I must admit I had to change my mind a
bit and now I try to convince Ms. Coffee Bean
as well.
There are multiple events that are not just
speculations, but are happening right now,
maybe you have heard of some of them yourself:
For one: When googling whether there is a
country in Africa that starts with k, this
thing comes up, which is clearly produced
by a language model.
It seems like there is at least enough AI
generated content such that search engines
draw that garbage in and highlight it.
Then, we see that there are ways of using
AIs to produce content farms sites which have
successfully squeezed money from at least
140 major brands.
How is this possible?
Well, because ads are often placed programmatically,
and until ad placement companies such as Google
Ads do not do something about this, the problem
will not stop.
These so-called news websites produce hundreds
of articles per day, for example by scraping
reddit and letting AI write something based
on the results.
In one case, they finally got caught when
people on the World of Warcraft subreddit
convinced the bot to publish news about the
release of a character that was entirely made
up and even included the sentence: “I just
really want some major bot operated news websites
to publish an article about this”.
But who knows how many more sites operate
like this?
To underline this, a new study from Europol
estimates that 90% of the Internet will be
AI generated by 2026.
What do you think about it?
Because if we are to believe this, then the
authors were not at all too pessimistic when
conducting their experiments on 90% model
generated content and just 10% real data!
So what to do in this whole situation?
On the one hand, we have this paper making
experiments in this worst-case scenario setting
of having little to no human generated data,
but did not experiment with pretraining large
models like ChatGPT, but only with finetuning.
On the other hand, we have papers that have
no troubles training on model generated data,
especially to mimic with smaller models the
capabilities of larger models.
But these procedures are to be taken with
care, especially in the large language model
field where evaluation is extremely hard.
It could be (and some people also think that)
these models trained on synthetic data show
great benchmarking scores and are as good
as ChatGPT on the benchmarks because they
mimicked its outputs, but they lack in everything
else and do not cover the huge application
diversity of the models have that were trained
with actual human data.
Ms. Coffee Bean is still undecided whether
recursive training is that bad or really unfixable.
I think, that until we know it, we have one
more reason to tag and watermark AI generated
content.
We should do it just for the record, so when
training the next generation of AI models,
we can choose to easily filter out AI generated
content.
Are you worried about AI generated content
flooding the internet?
We’ll read what you think in the comments
and hope to see you next time!
Okay, bye!